ではよろしくお願いします
今日のダンマパダの偈は七十五番目
アニャーヒラーブーペニサーアニャーニッバーナガーミニーエーワメータンアビニャーエビクブッダッササーワコサッカラーンナービナンデイヤヴィヴェカマヌブールハエ
今日はすごい簡単な話になると思います
一応テキストをお持ちになっていますので
言葉の意味を見てみましょう
アニャーヒラーブーペニサーアニャーニッバーナガーミニー
アニャーっていうのは違いますよという意味なんですね
別ですよ 違いますよという
ラーブーペニサー まぁ
財産を得ることやら得をすることやらね
これはラーブというんですね
ウペニサーっていうのは
その縁があるということ
お金に 財産に 幸福に縁があるということね
いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
もう財産を獲得する道
それと違います それは違う道である
アニャーニッバーナガーミニー
涅槃に達する道 ニッバーナガーミニーっていうのは涅槃に
涅槃へ行く道ですね それがまたアニャー
違いますと そこでただ道二つあります
それぞれ違う道であると
世俗的に財産に恵まれる道と涅槃に達する道
これが一本の道じゃないんだよということなんですね
それぞれ違いますと エーワメータンアビニャーエ
これよく知っておいて
このようであると 真理はよく知っておいて
ビクブッダッササーワコ
ブッダッサ釈尊のサーワコ弟子である比丘たちは
サッカラーンナービナンデイヤ
人々から受けるこのお供えとかね
お布施とかね そういうものはサッカラーっていうんですね
ナービナンデイヤ それほど喜ばないんだよと
喜んではならんと ヴィヴェカアヌブールハエ
遠り 離れることに アヌブールハエっていうのは一生懸命頑張るっていう意味なんですね
では 一般的な意味は 世俗的に豊かになる道と涅槃に達する道っていうのはそれぞれ違います
仏弟子たる比丘はそれをよく知って
世俗的な あの 何といいますかね
利益ではなくて そういう利益
離れることについて一生懸命真剣に励むべきであると
簡単ですね 意味は ラーバ
じゃあこれから言葉一つ一つ解説します
ラーバっていうのは利益ということですね
俗世間できている場合は
いろいろ我々は収入がなくちゃいけないんですね
生活する場合は 食べるために
生活するために いろいろ収入が必要になるんです
収入だけではなくて 土地やら家やらね
いろいろ車やら いろんなものが必要になるんです
人間には生まれつきそういうものはないんです
何もなく生まれますけど
それから一生懸命頑張って
たくさん富をもう獲得して
まぁ死にます 普通の世界の生き方っていうのは
とにかく収入を得ることなんです
小さい時に勉強するということはどういうことかというと
やっぱり大きくなったら
まぁなんとか職が手に入るようにということです
で そうでなきゃ困るんですね
親が ということで まあ子供にしたっても
勉強したりする場合は
まあ目的がありまして
仕事を見つかると何か職を見つかるということで
まあ勉強したりするんです
このウパニシャッドっていうのは
この原因にもウパニシャッドという言葉を使うし
だから利益を得るための原因なんですね
それはどういうことでしょうかね
やっぱり勉強しているということは
一つ得利益を得るための原因でしょうし
何も学んでないと言えば
もう全然仕事はなくなるでしょうに
いろいろ技術を学んだりすると
習ったりすると まあそれも一つの利益を得るための原因になります
だから人々はいろいろそういう能力というかね
利益を得るための能力
それは身につかなくてはならないんですね
そうでないとこの世の中で生きていられません
ですから 俗世間の人々は一生懸命この能力を身につこうと思って頑張ってます
それがラブウパニシャッドということなんです
しかし 出家の場合はこれが違いますよと
出家したということは
家を捨てたということなんですね
この家というのは まあ象徴的な言葉で
俗世間を全部捨てたということなんです
アガーラスマアナガーリャンパッバジョティというのは
まあ家を離れて家なき出家しましたと
この家っていうのは ただ自分の家から出たという意味じゃないんです
普通日本語で言ってる家ではないんです
このシステムそのものから出ていくんです
世間 世間という 世間というシステムそのものから出て
だから世間でやっていることはもう何もやりません
もう出て行っちゃったんです
そこでもしも誰かがもうその世間システム組織から出て行って
また同じことをやっているならば
もう話にならないんですね
もうあまりにもおかしいんです
だから出家してから何を身についた方が収入になるでしょうかとかね
金儲かるためにどうすればよろしいでしょうかとかね
考えてるならば もう出家になってないんですね
それは全部辞めたと 家族も辞めたと
結婚も辞めたと 仕事も辞めたと
俗世間も生きるためにやっている
その俗世間のシステム
組織からもう全部もう離れた
それを全て辞めたということにならなくちゃいけないんです
で なんでそれを辞めるのかというと
やっぱり涅槃という別な目的がありまして
それに頑張るんです だから出家っていうのはもう怠け者の行為ではないんです
仕事はややこしいとかね
しち面倒くさいとか やりたくはないとかね
親は気に入らないとかね
会社の同僚がもう気に入らないとか
そんなことで出家したっても
もうそれは出家にならないんですね
それは結局は怠けということで
やっぱり知恵でもって理解して出家しなくちゃいけないんです
では 俗世間の人々のこの心の働き
やっぱりいつでも何か収入を得るという
何か得をする 利益を得るという
あの気持ちがね ずっとあるんです
で それを忘れてしまえば
かなり困ることにもなります
だから 俗世間でもしっかりする人々は
こういうこういうことをしたら
どんなことになるのかとか
ちゃんと計算して利益を得るか
得らない 得られないかどうかとね
ちゃんと計算して もう生きているんです
で 俗世間でも知恵のない人々は
とにかく利益を得たいだけの気持ちで
もう何でもかんでもということでやってしまって
もう倒産したりもするんです
欲だけあって で そういう風にもかなりこの
この間もテレビで一人の人が出ていたんですけど
なんか十五億円ぐらいお金があったりして
今まあマイナス四億ぐらいだということで
いわゆるもう借金で 全てなくなって
まあ大変な状態になっていると
それでも頭が悪いなとね
みんなに非難されましたけどね
だからそういうことになるのは
やっぱり俗世間の生き方もはっきり知らないんですね
俗世間にしても ちゃんと理性的に生きていないと
俗世間は安定しません
感情で生きていると決してうまくはいかないんです
まあそれは俗世間の話で
やっぱり闇雲にあれこれとやったりしたっても
収入を得るわけじゃないし
もしかするとちょっと間違っちゃえば
自分の持っている財産まで全部消えてしまう可能性もあるし
だからそういうところで俗世間で生きている人々は
しっかり頭の中で考えて
理性に基づいてどう生きれば収入が増えるのか減らないのかということを考えて生活しなくちゃいけなくなるんです
それでなんで出家するのかというと
やっぱりその思考パターンででは悟りに達することは大変です
だから この心理的に頭の考え
パターンをね それを変えるんです
それを変えたところで
まあ悟りに達することは可能になるんです
[背景音楽]だからこれ
あんまりこの形で何とかなるわけじゃないんです
で これはね やっぱり心の中のこの思考の流れの転換ですよ
大体形でごまかしてやろうというよく思ったりするんですけどね
出家しちゃえばいいでしょうとかね
そうはうまくはいかないんです
形だけ変えたんだからといって
心は出家しているかないかというね
心が出家しなきゃダメなんです
うん そのポイントなんですけど
そこすごく説明は難しいんですけどね
まあ在家生活するとね
何か得る 何か得るという利益を得る
利益を得るという思考ですから
やっぱりずっと何が目的にしているのかで
この体を維持することなんですね
体を維持するといっても
それは肉体のことでね
だから肉体を維持することを考えてるのね
もう家を作りたいと思っちゃっても
結局は肉体のためでしょうし
まあ気分がいいんじゃないかなと言うかもしれませんだけど
気分もいいかもしれませんだけど
結局はまあ肉体はメインになるんですね
だからその基本的にこの悟りに達する場合
一番邪魔になるのはこのもう五蓋ありますからね
5つの邪魔がありましてね
1番目カマーチャンダですね
欲というものね そこで欲っていうのはこの体に対する依存なんですね
だから在家でいる場合は
この五蓋の第1もそのままなんです
そのために生きているんです
悟りに達しようと サマ
瞑想でも成功しようと思っちゃうと
五蓋を乗り越えなくちゃいけない
五蓋の中で４つは精神的なもので
1番目は普通肉体的なことなんですね
肉体に対する愛着 体に対する愛着
体に対する愛着っていうのは
まあ美しいものを見たいとかね
綺麗な声を聞きたいとか
美味しい味を味わいたいとかね
そういう思うことなんですけど
それは仏教的な分析で
俗世間ではそうは思ってないんですからね
もっと大雑把で考えていますからね
金儲かりたいと それはものすごい変な考え方で
だから苦しみの 大きくなるし
金儲かるのは何のためかとちゃんと分析してみた方がよろしいしね
その方が楽に生活できるし
例えば美味しいものを食べたいんだからいっぱい金儲かりたと
目的は美味しいものを食べることだったら
自分でいろいろね 美味しい料理を作ることを学んでいれば
お金がなくても美味しい料理を食べられることはできるし
だからいろいろ楽に生きる方法っていうのはちゃんと考えてみればできないわけでもないんですけど
結婚したいとかね 家族を作りたいとか
いろんなことを人間は考えているんですね
外国旅行したいとか 全国日本で大きな商売やりたいとか
そういうふうな この あまりにもこの大雑把で考えるんだからね
結構大変ですよ 具体的に考えておけば
人生っていうのはそんなに難しいということになりません
それにしても 俗世間の生き方というのは
ずっとこの五蓋の第一に引っかかっているのです
また破らなくちゃいけないものはまた４つもあるんですけど １
番目でもう止めているんですね
肉体に対する 体に対する愛着
それで出家する場合は
これをこの第一をまず破るんです
出家ということは その生きるために
生きるために生きるという世界を捨てるんです
生きるために生きると
両方使わなくちゃいけないんです
なぜならば 出家した人が解脱をするために生きるんだからね
だから涅槃に達するために生きるか
生きるために生きるかという
だから ちょっと日本語変かもしれませんだけど
この言葉を使わなくてはいけなくなっちゃうんです
在家の世界ではもうやっぱり生きるために
あらゆることをやっているんです
出家は生きるためではないんです
脱出するために 解脱 涅槃に達するためにまた生きるんです
そういうわけで 道が２つになります
それで注釈書でも書いてあるところは
この 一旦出家したら大変なことになるんです
こちらにも長い長いエピソードありまして
これもう10ページぐらいもありますから
もうもう読むのをやめちゃったんです
もう だからこのちょっと参考にすることはやめますけど
一部ある子供が出家しようとする
その場合は 比丘たちは
その子供にこう言うんですよ
出家はね 難しいんだよと
どういうことかというと
温かいものを欲しい場合は冷たいものをもらったりするんだよと
冷たいもの欲しい時はすごい温かいものをもらったりするんだよと
それから出家したら もうやっと生きてるだけだよと
あんたはえらい贅沢で生きてきてね
無理じゃないのと お坊さんたちが反対するんです
それでもその子はまあ言う通りにやりますから
出家しますということで出家する
出家して頑張ってはいるんですけどね
[背景の雑音]それでこの実際のところをちょこちょこっと言ってみると
出家した人がね 出家しても生活しなくちゃいけない
それで托鉢に出る 托鉢に出たらご飯もらうかもらわないかさっぱりわからない
ご飯もらったらそれでいいんですけど
もらわなかったらどうしましょうかと
で 冬になる 冬になってくると
まぁ毛布やらいろいろあった方がいいんですけど
もし薄い衣しかなかったならばどうしようかと
で 昔はね もう大変厳しかったんですね
全くのもうそういうところはもう考えてもない
そこでもう森の中やら
もうもう何か建物みたいなものがあってもね
そんなにもう立派なものではないし
で 冬を過ごさなくちゃいけない
だからずっと寒くて 体震えていて
それでろくにご飯ももらってない場合は
なおさら寒さに耐えることはできなくなっちゃうしね
その時かなり困るんですよ
しかし 体に対する愛着を捨てているならば
何のこともないんです
体に対する愛着がある場合は
もう激しく悩む羽目になっちゃうんです
修行はしたいんだけど
もうこんな寒さでもうどうにもならんというね
身動きできないんだと
それだけじゃなくて もう体病気になったり
いろいろ出来事起こる可能性もあるし
そういうどんな苦労があっても
体に対して愛着を捨てているならば
いわゆる心は出家しているならば
全然問題はないんです
心が出家していない場合は
もうやっぱり悩む羽目になるんですね
やっぱり寒いんだから何かもう毛布でも１枚あればありがたいなとかね
ちゃんと窓もドアもしっかり閉めることができるところがあればいいんじゃないかなとかね
そう思ったり悩んだりする
それでなおさら悪いことは
出家したらこの業が はっきり機能するんですよ
出家は単純に業の力だけで生きているんです
在家の人々は利益を得るために頑張っているんだからね
あまり業は感じないんです
そんなに恵まれてない人でも
そんな考える余裕がないので
一生懸命仕事をしたり
いろんなことをやってますからね
だから自分が一生懸命頑張っているんだから
それなりに何か利益を得るんです
すごく苦労してでも 食べるものやら何かね
住むところやら 家賃とかね
払えるようになって アパートであっても
なんとか家賃も払って
ギリギリで生活している場合はね
そんなに業のことは感じないんです
出家になっちゃうと もう全て利益のために生きることをやめているんだから
だから自分の業の力だけで残りの人生を生きていかなくちゃいけないんです
業っていうのはやっぱりもうたくさんあるんだからって
たくさん機能しないでしょうし
いったん生まれたら その生まれでどんな業が業でしょうかということは決まってしまいますからね
過去でいっぱい徳が積んでいるんだそうと言っても
今世で機能する業がありますからね
その業の力だけにリミットされます
だから出家した場合は
この業がすごく働きますから
恵まれているお坊さんたちが托鉢に行くと
結構冬は冬に適した食べ物をもらったり
夏は夏に適した食べ物をもらったり
冬になってくると 在家の方々はもうそろそろ冬でしょう
このお坊さんは森の中で大変なことになるんだから
何とか毛布でもあげましょうとかね
ってあげたりする 過去
業が 徳がそれほどないお坊さんにはないんです
だから それ なおさらすごい大変なことになるんです
一緒に生活しているんですけど
一人が結構ご馳走をもらったりして
一人がもう大さじ 2つしかご飯もらってないとかね
で その場合でも やっぱり精神的に結構苦労しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そういうとこを見ても
何も思わないでいなくちゃいけないんです
かなり昔の出家というのはすごい厳しかったんです
例えば こういうイメージを持ってみてください
例えば 森の中にお坊さんたちが５ ６
人住んでいる それで村から人々がそっちに来て
なんとかお坊さんいますか
なんとかお坊さんいますかと
一人か二人だけ探して 「
お坊さん もうせっかく会ってよかった」と 「
もう明日はお布施ありますから来ていただけませんか」とかね
で 他の３人はもう そういう接待ないし
その３人は托鉢に出る
この２人がその接待された家に行って
もうご飯いっぱい食べて森に入ると
あの３人がずっと村を歩いたって
もしかするとそんな大した食べ物をもらわないかもしれませんし
しかし ５人がまだ一緒に生活を修行しなくちゃいけないんですね
そうするとすごく落ち込んだりする可能性ありますよ
で 大変ですよ ご飯もらったお坊さん２人 「
まあ私たちは恵まれてあんた方は徳がないんですね」とか
そう思ったら ものすごい大変なことになるし
それで自分たちの修行できなくなっちゃうし
逆にあの３人のお坊さんも「私は徳がないんだからね
本当に困ったもんだな」とかね
思ったやり場 いっぱいお布施もらう人々に対して嫉妬したりしちゃうとね
これで修行は終わりになっちゃうし
だから精神的にかなり試練というか
そういうあの世界で出家っていうのは
決して楽な世界じゃないんです
すごく光り輝いている人を見て
全くもうそれはまるっきりもない人もいる
しかし比丘はそれは全く気にしてはならないんです
出家したんだからみんな一緒やということで生活しなくちゃいけないんです
それからこの 精神的にすごい健康でしっかりしているということは
みんなにできることでもないし
で 精神的に弱いっていうのは自我がすごくあるっていうことなんです
自我意識がある人は弱いんですね
エゴがある人は それで出家していて
エゴがある人がいるとすると
他のお坊さんたちは色々お布施もらったり
もう何のことなくお布施もらったりする場合はね
あ これはまずいと 何とかしなくちゃと思ったりするんです
自分も何かしなくちゃ
もうお布施もらったりしないんではないかと
と思ったりして 色々工夫するんですね
必要なものをもらうために
ブッダがスジョンロムを言うのは
やっぱりその場合は必ず悪いことをする羽目になるんだよと
だからこの 徳があまりないお坊さんでも
やっぱりいっぱいもらえるように
信者さんに愛されるように
頑張らなくてはいけないと思った時点で
やることは全部道が間違っているんです
こちら具体的な色々例がありますけどね
例えば一つの家からご飯ほんのちょっと
ひとさじもらったりする
次の家に行ったところで
もしその家の人々が あ
ご飯もらってるんだ じゃああげなくてもいいんだと
もっと別なものを差し上げるかもしれませんし
あるいは自分がまたご飯しか持ってないんだから
あのお坊さんにご飯もらってるんだから
他のお坊さんにあげるそうと思う可能性もあります
これはあまり皆様にもう全然もうわからない世界ですからね
タイとかね ミャンマーでもね
田舎のお寺とかね 行ってみるとわかると思いますけど
人々は自分好きなものを用意して待ってますからね
仏教の国だから別に誰も苦労してないんですが
やっぱりそれでもタイなんかはね
朝ものすごい朝早く托鉢に出ますからね
六時半 七時になるとお坊さんたちはみんなもう托鉢終わってるし
それで朝早く起きて みんなね
何か うちで何か料理を作って道路で待っている
それで三人がご飯だけ
白いご飯だけ作って待っているならば
前の人からね もう十分ご飯もらったお坊さんがこちらに来たら
もう見たらもう修行はいっぱいもらってるし
そうするとこの信者さんがそれあげないことになる可能性あります
せかするとまたまたお坊さんたち来るんだから
このお坊さんが十分取っているんだから大丈夫ですということに
逆に先に来た人々に全部ご飯をあげちゃ
後から来る人々なくなるしね
信者さんが信者さんの家庭のこと考えるんだから
それはもう誰もわからないんです
それであるお坊さんが
例えばご飯もらったんだから
もしかしてこのご飯は足りませんと
これではほんのちょっともう指3分取れるぐらいのご飯ではね 1
日生活できません しかし
あの信者さんがご飯あると思っちゃうと
ほんのちょっとしかくれないんだからって思ってね
で 自分も鉢を出す場合は
もらったご飯がちょっと見えないようにすると
信者さんに見えないんだから
じゃあちょっと大さじ多めに差し上げましょうと思ったりするでしょうに
それだけでもすごい悪い行為であると
だから 大変厳しいんですよ
精神的に 落ち着いているということは
まあちょっと大さじ 1杯はもらいましたけど
次の家にも行くと その家の人がご飯もらってるんだから
じゃあ他のお坊さんにあげますよと思ったら
まあしょうがないんです
だから そこですごい無執着の心でいるっていうことは
もう大変な厳しい修行になるんです
だから この無執着の気持ちで生活するということは
これはなかなか大変で
まあ結構みんなそこでもうみんなというか
もうものすごいほとんど失敗する
なかなか無執着の心で何にも頼らない心でいるということはね
例えばね 鉢は見たことあるでしょうかね
ちょっと丸いあれですからね
あれはわざとその形に作ってるんですよ
なかなか中身見えないんですね
だからどうしても都合が悪いんです
中身見えないんだから
もう余計に出す場合もある
それも都合が悪いし あるいは出さない場合もあるし
例えば自分の鉢をわざと信者さんの前にずっと伸ばして出すこともダメなんです
例えば何かスープとか何か液体のものをあげようとしちゃうと
もうサジで取ったところでこぼれたりする
あ これはまずいといて
さっと鉢を前に出しちゃって
全部取ろうとした それもやっぱり自分がたくさんもらおうと思ったことになるんです
だから 微妙にでも欲が絡んだらダメなんです
信者さんがお坊さん ちょっと箸を前に出していただけませんか？と言ったら
まあそれでいいんですけど
それでない限りはね まあだからそれはいいんです
時々おばあちゃんたちがすごい厳しくて怒鳴ったりもします
そんなことであげられません
出してくださいとかね
あんたねとか怒られる時よくありますね
あんたね こっち出す それで勝手にとったりして
まあそれで その場合はものすごい信者さんの方がね
怒られても ものすごいお坊さんたちのことをね
心配して慈しんで持ってるんだから
まあそれは全然もう何のこともないんですけど
で そういう 人でない限りはもうすごい精密に気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
まあまあ それは蓄積習慣がある場合はそうなってしまいますけどね
だからこの精神的な出家っていうのは
もうなかなか大変な世界なんです
まあ日本ではね あの連中仕事もしないんだそうとかね
仕事をしないことをすごい自慢げにしているんだそうか
それももうもの勘違いもいいところなんです
我々大乗仏教ではね 出家の仕事をしているんだそうとかね
仕事をして食べているんだそうとかね
中国仏教ではちゃんと田んぼを畑作ってお寺で食べてるんではないかとかね
俗世間の目で見るとかっこいいんです
例えば中国ではね もうお寺で料理作ることになって
もう畑も作ることになったりして
中国社会はもうあまり仏教を支えてくれなかったしね
まあ仏教はすごいんだから中国人に影響を与えたんですけど
別に中国人が仏教をちゃんと受けて
もう長い歴史でね まあ伸びてあげたっていうことはまあもうほとんどないんです
が ものすごいお寺があったりとかね
まあそれは仏教の力でね
まあだからそういう目で見てね
自分たちで自給自足というんですか
自給自足しているんだと
この少々の人々はね もう何だこれはとかね
思ったりするのはね それはまあ仏教は知らないんだから
勘違いであってね こちらはもう徹底的な無執着の心に挑戦しているんですよ
それは命かけてやっているんです
自給自足の世界じゃないんです
自給自足になった時点で
もう仏道からもう脱線なんです
やっぱり体のために 食べるために何とかしているんだからね
とっても質素な生活をしているかもしれませんよ
あるいは出家したお坊さんたちは何のことなく
すごい楽々に贅沢にいるかもしれません
よく言われることは 肉も食べたりして
あんた方は坊主じゃないかとかね
だからしょうがないんですそれが
出家してちゃんと無執着の世界でいる人々は
もう何も自分体のためには何もやらないんです
ここで信者さんが肉の料理を差し上げたんだけだから
それを何のことなく食べると
しかし 自給自足のお坊さんたちがそんな贅沢はしようとも思わない
大根の葉っぱと玄米ご飯だけで食べて
まあ坐禅に励んでいるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれでもこちらの方がもう本物の道になっちゃうんです
まあ昔ね いろいろそういう交流あったんだからね
まあ話し合ったりする場合はね
よく私には何も言えないんですからね
難しい世界でしょうし
理解していただくのは大変厳しいでしょうし
だから座禅とかそういうことをいろいろあっちこち旅をしたりとかね
日本にもお坊さんたちがね
有名な人々とかね まあ今もいると思いますけどね
で やっぱり自分が玄米ご飯と大根の葉っぱだけで生活しているとかね
偉そうなことを言ったってもね
やっぱりまあ 自給自足ということになってくると
体のために何かやるっていうことになっちゃうんですね
だからそれが俗世間のことで
体を維持管理するために頑張るっていうことはね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは肉体のことをやっぱり精神的な出家なんですね
だから出家という形を取ると同時に
やっぱり精神的にも出家にならないと
結果厳しく感じるんです
精神的に出家したならば
ものすごい楽っていうことになるんです
お釈迦様の義理の兄弟のアルル都尊者とかね
話がありまして いつでももうよく口癖みたいな感じで
なんてすごいことですか
なんてすごいことですかとか
よかったなとか何か言うんですね
ああ よかったなとか お坊さんたちは勘違いしたんですね
勘違いしてもうもう批判したんです
もう出家していますけどね
あの王子は出家しているのに
宮殿にいた時のこととか思い出しているでしょうとかね
だからよかった よかったとかね
昔のことを思い出したりするんではないかとか
それがお釈迦様に言われてね
お釈迦様は 聞くんですね
どういうことかと 言ったら
アルル都尊者の答えはね
私はね サイケデいた時はね
ずっと 24時間警備でしたけど
ちゃんと自分を守っているんですね
軍人たちがというかね
家来の人々は でもずっと怯えていたんだと
それでも誰かに殺されるかもしれませんし
毒殺されるかもしれませんし
外で自由では歩けないし
24時間守られていた時も
私には瞬間たりとも恐怖感から抜けることはできなかったと
ほら 今どうですかと 誰もいない
警備やってるガードマンは
でも誰かに殺されるとか毒殺されるとか
ひとかけらもないんだと
だから森とか見るともう楽しいんだと
なんてすごい安らぎかと
だからなんてすごいかと
だからもうずっと言ってしまいますよと
いうことで お坊さんたちはやっぱりお釈迦様の兄弟に出会って
もうそんな変なことあるわけないので
また開き直りましたけど
それ出家してね たまたま何かもらったりする場合はね
そのもらったものに執着してしまう可能性もあります
例えば毛布 1枚もらうと
そうするとなかなかもらわないんですけど
もらったならばね これ大変価値があって
すっごく大事に大事に執着してしまう可能性もあります
それはダメでしょうしね
ですから 涅槃を目指す目指している比丘が微妙にでも身振り手振り
ちょっと挨拶してあげたりとかね
笑ってあげたりとかね
いろいろ人気を買うことは絶対ダメでしょうと
信者さんはやっぱりちゃんと挨拶してくれる人には人気ある
面白い話とかね 冗談とかね
言ってくれると あのお坊さん
すごくいいお坊さんだとかね
あるいは自分のことをよく心配してくれると
よく名前とか覚えておくと
そういう人はいないわけじゃないんですけどね
村の人々の名前も片っ端から知っていて
もう家柄 家の間の関係やらね
職業やらあれこれとかなんかもう全部データバンクみたいに
まあタイミャンマーどうか分かりませんだけど
自分の国だったら結構いるんです
で 政府にはね 各村に あの
何て言いますか 人がいますけど
あの村に住んでいて あの村のいろいろ仕事をするというね
だから村に政府が決めた公務員だからね
彼はみんなの名前リストを持ってるし
各家のことは個人的にしっかり知っていて
経済状況からもう何でもかんでも
だからこの 何かに行く場合は必ずその人から招待状をもらわなくちゃいけないんですね
そういう人々よりも 坊さんに来て
その人は自分のセクション以外知らないんだからね
もうデータが入ってない
出さないんだからね 自分の管轄の各家の名前やら全部データ持っている
それからそこら辺に行ったりして
行って 自転車に乗ってあっちこっち行ったり
見たり調べたり 人々毎日喋ったりして
まあそういう関係を持っている
お寺だったらもうそういう村 2つも3つとかお寺の段階になりますからね
お坊さんが全部知っていて
よく名前とか何でもかんでも知っていると
信者さんも随分もう喜んで面倒見てあげたりはする
しかし 本当のブッダの出家の世界では
そういうことはもうダメなんですね
それで人気買いますからね
いかなる場合でも人気買ってはアカン
業できてなくちゃいけないんです
業があるならば もう食べるものはもらう
業がないんだったらもらわない
業があったら着るものやら住むところやらちゃんとあると
業がなかったらもう知らんという世界でなければいけないんですね
そういうわけで 解脱を目指す人は
アナンデーネーヴァアンデーナヴィア
目が見えるんだけど 目が見えない人のように生活しなくちゃいけない
ちゃんと喋れますけど
言葉喋れない人のようにいなくちゃいけないんだと
耳がちゃんと聞こえますけど
耳が全く聞こえないような生活しなきゃ
いわゆるこのものすごい無関心というか
無執着の気持ちでいなくちゃいけないんだと
だから隣のお坊さんがいっぱいお布施をもらって
もう食べ物だけではなくて
必要なもう他のものもいっぱいもらってあったっても
自分には目が見えない
ような感じでいなくちゃいけない
だからお坊さんたち同士であの村のあの右の道の一番最後の家にいる何々さんって
本人はやっぱり聞こえん
知らないという状況でいなくちゃいけないんです
聞いたことがないんですけど
毎日行く道かもしれませんけど
まあそれはわかりやすく
そういうどういう生活するべきかということでね
とにかくそういうことで
在家生活とまるっきり違う生き方は出家生活であるということで
だからそれは出家生活よりは涅槃の道が違うと
俗世間の道がまた違いますよということ
それをよく知りなさい
知っておいて サッカーランナービナンデーヤ人のお布施とか期待するもんじゃないんだよと
ヴィパッサナーアヌブーヘーっていうのは
ヴィパッサナーっていうのは
心はすべてのもの 執着から離れることに一生懸命育てて育てて進んで持っていってくださいと
これこの解脱という状況っていうのは
仏教以外はないんです
悟りの道っていうのは
ブッダ以外誰も考えたことはないんです
どんな宗教も同じっていうことは全くもあり得ないんです
仏教以外はどんな宗教もろくなものじゃないんで
同じこと言ってるんです
ただお互い殺し合いやってるだけで同じこと言ってるんです
勝手に神様を作って それで神様の争いなんですね
キリスト教でイスラム教っていうのも激しくぶつかったりしてる
で 言ってることは結局同じですね
神は人間を作って死んじゃったら
神を信じる人は天国に行くと
そこは永遠ですよと 違うところは
イスラム教でははっきりと
死んでからずっと寝ていなくちゃいけない
キリスト教も結局は同じですけどね
それで神様はある日がありまして
その日で審判するんですね
死ぬたびに じゃああんた天国
あんた地獄って それもやらないんです
今何やってるか分かりませんだけど
最後の日があるんです
審判の日っていう なんでそんなタイムテーブルを作ったかとわからないんですね
神にタイムテーブル必要でしょうかとかね
好き勝手にやればいいでしょうに
だから とにかくキリスト教でもそういうタイムテーブルがあるみたいし
イスラム教でもタイムテーブルがあるみたいし
だったら同じことじゃないかと
そうじゃないとお互い殺し合いやるんです
最後の預言者がモハメッドでなければダメと
だからモハメッドが最後の預言者
冗談でしょうとは言いますけど
もう一人頭おかしい人っていくらでも現れるんですけど
認めないと 邪教 キリスト教になってくると
イエスは預言者ではないんですね
神ですね しかしイスラム教はあれは預言者ですよと
でもその人の後でもう最後の預言者が現れましたからね
それでも本当にくだらないことにすごい戦っているんです
現代ヒンドゥー教も同じ
何やってるかあんまりわかりませんだけどね
かなり笑われることだけは確かなんです
だから宗教っていうのはどうったことは考えられませんよ
執着の世界なんですよ
死ぬのは嫌だとかね 苦しみのは嫌だと
楽に生きたいんだと だから永遠なことをイメージをする
そちらにあるのは この生きることに生に対する執着なんです
だから生に対する執着を語る世界と執着を捨てることを語る世界っていうのは全く違うんですね
だから仏教から見れば
宗教は地形といってね
俗世間で生活する人々と宗教に凝り固まっている人々とどんなどった差がないんです
どちらでもただ生に執着しているだけ
一部がこの世 この世で楽しく生きることに執着しているし
一部がこの世はどうでもいいんだから天国でしっかりやってやろうと思っている
その差なんですよ 涅槃っていうのは
そういう普通の人間に考えられること
難しい考えられることではありません
これが無執着の精神で離れるというね
パヴィリッタというヴィヴェーカ
というすごい深い心理的な現象があるんです
ものに依存すると心が弱くなって苦しみを味わうと
それで一つ一つ依存を捨てると
捨てて捨てていくために
この依存を切るということで
すごいしっかりするんですね
心が ですから 普通の人にはもう想像も考えることも何もできない状態になってしまう
だからゴウディカ阿羅漢がね
自殺して マーラさんがね
どこに生まれたでしょうかねと
マーラさんもなんかすごい不思議に思うんですね
やっぱりあのお坊さんがね
しっかり修行してましたし
真面目でしたし しかし瞑想はできなかったんだから
お腹が立って自殺したんですけど
その場合はどこに生まれ変わるでしょうかなとかね
ちゃんと修行していて
亡くなったら もう成功すれば悟りに達することはマーラさんも知ってるし
悟りに達しなかったら
もう天国とかどこかに生まれ変わるでしょうと
この場合はどうなるのかと
自殺しちゃったんだから
とわからなくて興味あったんですね
それでこの心がどこに生まれたんでしょうかとも調べるんですね
必死で それでお釈迦様が「あなたにね
見つかりっこはないんだよ」と
その心は ゴウディカさんがね
残念ながら悟りに達しましたよと
お釈迦様がね 自分の勝利を言うんです
だからものに頼ると その分心は弱くなるんです
だからどっしり依存しているのは俗世間はね
だからすごく弱いんですね
心が だから一つ一つ捨てていく世界であると分かって
それはもう実行しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことだから ものを得る世界とものを捨てる世界ってことになりますから
道が別々になるんです
例えば ずっとものを得たい得たいと思っちゃうと
なんか自分がね ブラックホールみたいに何でも吸い込むような状態でしょうに
しかし 離したいと言うと
すごいそちらに逆の力なんですね
捨ててしまう 全部 そうなってくると
どんどんすごい力強くならなくちゃいけないんですね
もう極限に一切捨てたということは
誰にも近寄れないということなんです
だから知ることはできないんです
得たいという人の場合は
もうもうそちら穴があるんだから
そこでもう知ることはできます
心が力になって 逆に全部捨ててしまっちゃうと
もうエネルギーは反対方向だからね
だから涅槃に達した心はどんなものかということを認識することは不可能なんです
はい  そこは難しい話を置いておいて
あの ただ仏道はね もう金儲けの道ではなくて
すごい心清らかにするものに依存しない世界であると理解しておけばいいんじゃないかなと思います
えーと